today we're going to make some daiquiris
one of the best and most
versatile cocktails around i'm going to
do it three different ways one the
traditional way which is just
white rum lime juice and simple syrup
and i'm going to do two variations the
strawberry daiquiri and the pineapple
daiquiri what you'll need for everything
is some white rum
fresh lime juice simple syrup a couple
of strawberries and some fresh pineapple
so i'm gonna build these simultaneously
in three different glasses
and you're gonna see how just with a few
tweaks you're gonna get three
totally different cocktails so first
we're gonna add our simple syrup
so this one will be our traditional it's
gonna be strawberry
this movie pineapple
i feel like i'm bartending right now all
right
for the strawberry daiquiri i'm just
gonna add
one strawberry and
muddle it
then for the pineapple daiquiri three
quarters of an ounce of pineapple
juice if you don't have pineapple juice
because fresh really is better
you can just muddle in some pineapple
chunks too that works great now let's
add some lime juice
just juiced this about five minutes ago
three quarters of an ounce
to balance out the simple syrup it's
just the same from here on out
and now two ounces of white rum
and that is it we're done we're going to
shake all of these fill them up with ice
[Music]
now i'm going to grab our glasses which
i have in the fridge with any cocktail
the colder your glasses are the better
especially for cocktails that are
straight up like this a colder cocktail
is a better cocktail do the traditional
one first
for drinks with muddled fruit i like to
use this fine strainer it catches any
bits that make it through the first
strainer and also some ice chips
makes the cocktail look better which i
think is important and it also gives it
a more even texture
all right and finally almost done we're
going to garnish the strawberry with
a little bit of a strawberry slice and
i'm going to cut a slice of pineapple
for our pineapple decor the traditional
daiquiri the strawberry daiquiri
and the pineapple daiquiri one drink
three variations but there are endless
ways you can customize this drink
if you add mint to it put it in a tall
glass with some soda it's a mojito
you're pretty much just limited by the
contents of your kitchen and your
imagination
if you like that recipe tell us some of
your favorite drinks you like to make at
home in the comments below and subscribe
to the gq channel we've got lots more of
[Music]
them